bonsoir aujourd'hui la loi climat a
commencé à être débattu par les députés
le dernier grand texte du quinquennat
dixit le gouvernement tous les articles
qui la composent cette fois viennent de
la convention citoyenne sur le climat
alors il y est question de transport de
logement d'alimentation avec à la clé
des milliers d'amendements ça promet des
débats il est vrai que la crise du colis
d'amis ni sur le devant de la scène plus
que jamais les enjeux environnementaux
et climatiques même si on ne sait
toujours pas d'où vient ce virus qui a
provoqué la pandémie
on reçoit ce soir julien bayou
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être
sur le plateau d'auditions publiques
c'est le rendez vous politique chaque
lundi pendant une heure sur lcp public
sénat avec le figaro et nous sommes
aujourd'hui le 8 mars c'est la journée
internationale des droits des femmes il
eu des manifestations à paris dans
plusieurs villes pour mettre en avant
les premières de corvée ces femmes qui
ont été au premier rang depuis le début
de la pandémie
il a été question d'égalité des salaires
entre hommes et femmes
d'autres sujets aussi la question des
violences sexuelles qui est au coeur de
certains slogans pour vous
quand on parle des droits des femmes qui
est serait la priorité
alors moi j'étais dans les
manifestations et c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup parlé récemment des violences
sexuelle et sexiste je pense qu'il ya un
enjeu majeur le fait qu'en fait on
tolère qu'une partie la plus grande
partie en fait les femmes représentent
51 52% de la population française en
tolère que cette population soit 1
sécurisé dans l'espace public les
transports notamment
mais même à la maison et que depuis
depuis qu'on le sait on ne prend
toujours pas les mesures qui s'imposent
pour éloigner par exemple le conjoint un
prédateur formé au consentement à
l'école au collège et au lycée dans les
administrations les policiers les juges
tous à un coût plus exactement un
investissement que le haut conseil à
l'égalité chiffré à un milliard d'euros
c'est d'ailleurs en phase avec les
revendications revendication des
associations comme nous toutes par
exemple et d'autres la fondation des
femmes et ce gouvernement a choisi de
temporiser de tergiverser de gagner du
temps au point que marlène schiappa qui
était alors ministre déléguée aux droits
des femmes avaient inventé je ne sais
même pas l'appeler grenelle mais un
grand sommet contre les violences faites
aux femmes pour accoucher de rien donc
pour vous il faudrait d'abord débloquer
ce milliard pour la formation
c'est ça que vous voulez dire oui bien
sûr les femmes aujourd'hui quand elle
souhaite porter plainte sont mal
accueillies dans les commissariats c'est
de notoriété publique il ya des refus le
plan c'est une priorité
il ya des culpabilisation des victimes
la justice n'est pas outillée et si bien
qu'il a finalement loin de 1% des
violeurs qui sont effectivement condamné
on a un problème de respect des femmes
dans ce pays et ensuite ça se traduit
également sur des inégalités salariales
alors en particulier les plus
vulnérables
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire là pour
le coup il faudrait augmenter les
salaires des femmes uniquement mais vous
avez une loi la loi yvette roudy qui
date maintenant de bientôt 40 ans j'ai
pu rencontrer yvette roudy et quelques
quelques années qui me disait à travail
égal salaire égal la france ne s'est
jamais donné vraiment l'ambition de le
réaliser
vous avez une loi de 2014 qui permet de
sanctionner des entreprises pensent est
avérée donc il faut appliquer les lois
déjà et bah oui il faut avoir des lois
et elle a sonné le nom d un message
insiste a donné le nom des entreprises
qui ne respectent pas la loi moi en tant
qu élue régionale j'aimerais pouvoir en
ile-de-france en ile-de-france en ile de
france élu régional
j'aimerais pouvoir écarter des marchés
publics les entreprises qui ne
respectent
la loi sur l'égalité femmes-hommes
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas avoir cette
liste je pense que c'est un enjeu majeur
de transparence est évidemment que ça
ferait changer les mentalités
là où des managers des ressources
humaines et des grands patrons là se
cachent derrière le secret professionnel
pour continuer de discriminer les femmes
à propos de manager vous savez que le
gouvernement étudie la possibilité
d'instaurer des quotas dans les
entreprises pour qu'il y ait plus de
femmes qui soient présentes dans les
instances dirigeantes est ce que vous
seriez pour ça alors là j'ai aussi
vraiment parce que c'est une proposition
qui a été faite le 7 mars 2020 par ce
gouvernement il ya un an et ça n'a pas
avancé
est ce que vous êtes favorable c'est à
fuir encore ça il ya une loi qui
existent dont on fête les 10 ans qui
s'appelle la loi zimmermann et donc
quand le gouvernement quand j'ai entendu
cette proposition je me demande vraiment
si il prend collectivement l'opinion
publique pour des idiots parce que ça la
loi copé zimmermann c'est sur les
conseils d'administration oui et là il
s'agit de les porter dans les instances
dirigeantes quelle qu'elles dirigent des
entreprises où qu'elles soient numéro
deux c'est ce que j'appelle les conseils
d'administration n'ont pas toujours
alors juste juste est ce que vous êtes
favorable c'est très simple oui ou non
vie oui bien sûr bien sûr mais pourquoi
attendre parce que cette proposition a
été faite le 7 mars 2020 bien noyer
s'est tendu entendu peut-être qu'on y
reviendra les exceptions qui viendront
bientôt sept ans ben non parce que ça ça
veut dire qu'il ne se passera rien parce
qu'une proposition de loi vous savez
très bien comme moi qu'en fait si ça
n'est pas le gouvernement qui la porte
alors elle est soumise à des allers
retours incessants c'est une députée la
république alors que le gouvernement
avait l'occasion de faire voter ses
avancées dans les différents projets de
loi passé et ne l'a pas fait aussi big à
ce que l'eau c'est bien pour dire que
cette soi disant cause du quinquennat
les droits des femmes pour aller vite et
complètement enterré bien en tout cas
vous êtes favorable plutôt aux quotas ce
serait une bonne idée on va parler
maintenant du projet de loi climat et
résidences ça s'appelle comme ça avec
brigitte boucher de lcp qui est avec 500
rads en me concentrant le sénat bonsoir
tam s'est voulu commencer logique oui
alors le projet de loi climat est
débattu à partir d'aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale est ce que pour
vous il ya 69 articles
il ya cinq mille amendements qui ont été
déposés est ce que pour vous c'est un
moment fort et important pour
l'écologiste que vous êtes ici à
l'assemblée on alors
j'aurais bien aimé mais cette loi elle
est vide ou plus exactement elle a été
vidée de sa substance
vous aviez la convention citoyenne pour
le climat 150 citoyens tirés au sort
formés aux enjeux du climat n'étais pas
écologiste au départ clairement et ils
nous l'ont dit il y avait des
abstentionnistes y avait des gens de
droite y avait des gens de gauche
d'extrême droite également et formés aux
enjeux du climat
éclairé par la science 1 eh bien ils ont
pris un train de mesures et c'est un
ensemble cohérent des 146 propositions
qu'elle porte et qui permettait
d'atteindre l'objectif de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'au
moins 40 mais ça tout ça d'accord on la
justice sociale oke donc non ça n'est
pas la grande référence pour tous ses
efforts quand je pense au travail fourni
par ces conventionnelles comme on les
appelle les 150 pour aboutir à ce que le
haut conseil pour le climat donc une
instance indépendante estime que ces 10%
de l'objet dont va revenir dans le
détail sur certaines mesures après mais
regarde un bar à combien on y revient
barbara mon public et donc la ministre
la transition écologique qui vient
justement des rangs d'europe écologie
les verts elle y était avant d'être dans
la majorité au gouvernement
elle a dit qu'elle s'opposerait à tout
recul à l'assemblée nationale est-ce que
vous lui faites confiance pour porter
ces mesures mais malheureusement les
reculs ils ont déjà eu lieu puisque le
président de la république avait promis
une transmission sans filtre avec 3
joker et dès le lendemain
bruno le maire enterrer la réduction de
tva sur le train la taxation du kérosène
la limitation de la publicité c'est ce
gouvernement qui a réintroduit les
pesticides néonicotinoïdes alors qu'il
avait promis de l'embarras président
n'est pas un garde-fou pour vous c'est
le problème c'est que ce gouffre
l'écologiste et donc on a eu si vous
souvenez si vous avez souvenez il ya eu
la crise des gilets jaunes et là le
président de la république a dit on va
faire un grand débat on pouvait se
douter que c'était aussi un moyen de
gagner du temps 500000 contribution sur
l'écologie il n'a rien fait ensuite la
convention citoyenne pour le climat soit
disant pour contourner l'assemblée qui
ne voulaient pas agir comme si le
président aujourd'hui n'avait pas la
main sur sa majorité est simplement
brigitte vous demander tout ce travail
barbara public vous connaît on n'a rien
quand même on arrive à un objectif qui
d'après le haut comme c'est bien sûr
parce que beaucoup de conventionnelles
ont voté 0 a toutes les mesures non je
parle du haut conseil pour le climat
estime que l' on est à 10 % de
l'objectif
ramenée à une note sur 20 10% ces deux
bons donc barbara broccoli vous n'en
attendait rien mais moi c'est de ce
gouvernement que bon je n'attends rien
malheureusement elle fait partie de ces
zones non mais vous auriez pu imaginer
avoir une alliée est là mais le problème
c'est que quand vous allez contre vous
bruno le maire un ministre de l'économie
et du budget le premier ministre qui
n'est pas écolo et le président de la
république qui n'est pas écolo non plus
vous pouvez avoir n'importe qui a miné
de l'écologie ça ne fonctionne pas la
rénovation thermique par exemple envers
gisement de centaines de milliers
d'emplois
un moyen de réduire les factures c'est
bon pour le porte-monnaie c'est bon
parti pourquoi ça n'avance pas je pose
au travers on pose le décor et on va
revenir sur les mesures de guerre
on a un gouvernement qui se pare de vert
qu'a dit que l'écologie c'est important
qui est champion de la planète je ne
sais quoi et qui quand il s'agit d'agir
ne bouge partie douala alors même que
des emplois sont en alors on va avancer
le gouvernement vocifère discuter d'un
projet de loi pour déclencher un
référendum entre disant l'environnement
dans la constitution l'article 1er cilly
à référendum ce que vous voterez oui je
vous dis ça dépend de la formulation
parce qu'en la matière
on peut pas se payer de mots quand on
touche à la constitution ce qui en fait
le règlement notre nom règles du jeu les
mots sont importants et donc moi je n'ai
pas encore de certitudes sur quels mots
quand on dit la loi garantit l'action ou
la préservation de la biodiversité
c'est évidemment beaucoup plus important
beaucoup plus contraignant pour le juge
et pour le législateur que quand on dit
favorise alors agir et je vais vous dire
sur les princes des montants les
écologistes avaient été les premiers à
demander l'inscription de
l'environnement l'article 1er sur le
principe c'est une victoire écolo qu'on
en vienne à débattre d'inscrire cette
question dans la constitution
simplement vous me demandez qui je vote
oui ou non moi j'attends d'avoir la
formulation et n'attendons pas
cette révision constitutionnelle pour
agir j'ai encore une fois j'ai la
fâcheuse impression que ce gouvernement
cherche à gagner du temps il nous dit
voilà le projet de loi il est en gros ça
pour ce à quoi une une montagne
d'efforts pour accoucher d'une souris
mais peut-être demain on fera le
référendum vous y croyez cette révision
constitutionnelle vous pensez que on va
pouvoir bien d'accord entre les deux
chambres la faire un deuil est vrai
qu'ils agissent maintenant c'est
maintenant qu'il ya 50 60 est ce que
vous croyez en mille morts de la police
jan vous demandez voyait le référendum
aura lieu penser que ça peut aboutir ou
pas alors votez pour des écologistes à
la prochaine présidentielle et ça ira
mieux voilà ce que je peux vous dire
mais ils vont réserver votre réponse si
vous voulez l'action mais s'ils
voulaient de l'action choisissez les
écologistes parce que surtout c'est bien
sûr de la convention citoyenne pour le
climat je peux vous dire celles et ceux
qui la mettent en oeuvre
ce sont les maires écologistes à
besançon anne vignot elle vous disais
artificialisation net et elle crée la
réserve foncière de ce projet de loi
climat il est prévu qu'il soit interdit
de faire des trajets en avion quand le
trajet en train peut être fait en moins
de 2h30
on voit que le secteur aéronautique
aujourd'hui à cause de la crise du coc
vide bas de laine que les avions sont
cloués au sol
est ce qu'il y a urgence selon vous a
imposé cette mesure
oui clairement la mesure initiale
c'était favoriser le train quand une
alternative existe pour les trajets de
moins de quatre heures
encore une fois c était vidé de son sens
parce qu'on tombe à deux ans sauf quand
y'a correspondance donc en fait on est
sur moins de 10% du trafic concernés on
sait que le trafic aérien
le kérosène n'est pas taxée faire que
votre carburant il est taxé n'est pas le
carburant des riches celui de l'avion ou
du fioul lourd pour les navires de
croisière
donc évidemment il ya tout un enjeu de
lutte contre les nuisances aériennes -
en ile-de-france et malgré que ce soit
mais ça on s'en sert gouffran ce parce
qu'il n'y a pas que lyon de france nord
de la france entière là vous parlez de
pigeons moi je perdais avion parce que
c'est un peu de riches la france inter
attendez la crise économique que
traverse le transport aérien est-ce
qu'il ya urgence à le faire j'y viens
oui il ya urgence malgré la crise c'est
précisément maintenant qu'on peut le
faire si vous voulez parce que on aide
énormément
air france à hauteur de plusieurs
milliards d'euros
si ça n'est pas là qu'on parte
accompagné de contrepartie quand est-ce
que vous avez les mettre en oeuvre
c'est votre argent public c'est mon
argent public est ce que c'est normal
que notre argent public en baisse
d'impôts sur les sur la cirgl sur le
carburant en subventions directes
finances des licenciements et de la
pollution
les maladies cardiovasculaires de nos
aînés et les bronchiolite de nos enfants
mais la réponse est majoritairement oui
c'est pas normal il faut mettre des
contreparties et c'est contrepartie
c'est la réduction des pollutions et
notamment des nuisances aériennes
millions de personnes qui sont
concernées a tendance à se battre et la
rénovation énergétique des logements qui
s'imposera à tous il y à des
propriétaires qui ne sont pas forcément
riches qui ont hérité d'un bien est ce
que vous ne craignez pas que ça rappelle
la taxe carbone qui a déclenché la crise
des gilet jaune à mais au contraire au
contraire j'aurais voulu dire sur
l'aéronautique que notre responsabilité
c'est les accompagner tout l'enjeu de
l'écologie c'est gérer les transitions
et donc si on dit on va vous aider vous
continuez comme comme avant ça ne
fonctionne alors sur le logement et vous
a posé une question brigitte sur le
léger ainsi que c'est une question de
principe si vous dites on va vous aider
parce qu'on sait pas faire et on vous
met de l'argent et fait comme vous
faisiez avant ça ne fonctionne pas
accompagnons les transitions à côté de
toulouse qik est très forte à m julien
bayou vous savez qu'on est passé au
logement l'âge est en train de vous
répondre sur les deux excusez moi mais
non mais non et investissons parce que
dans l'aéronautique à des milliers de
compétences qu'on peut utiliser sur
d'autres envies mois une seconde lui
donc jouer en lan on veut gagner du
temps il n'y a pas que lui donc
islamique
voilà mais comme le sujet est important
les brigitte vous disais est ce que
l'âge de la rénovation thermique pour
des jeux pour des gens qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens ça pourrait
déclencher le phénomène taxe carbone qui
avait déclenché la réactiver cette crise
mais non ma condition d'avancer les
sommes l'enjeu de la rénovation
thermique
c'est le porte monnaie
c'est le confort pouvoir il ya 17 % des
françaises et de français qui disent
avoir froid chez eux mais bien une
question confort c'est même une question
de dignité humaine c'est une question de
santé parce que des enfants qu'on froid
qui développe des otites à répétition ça
veut dire des retards d'apprentissage
dans la lecture et ça vous avez du mal à
le rattraper ça peut ça fait générer des
7e reste et c'est peut-être des des
séquelles les difficultés
d'apprentissage c'est une question
climat c'est une question santé
particules fines et autres et c'est une
question d'emploi bien j'étais agent pas
s'arrêter là c'est une autre question on
a discuté d'une opération réussie et
donc nous misons nous disons
accompagnons ces ménages 0 avance 0
reste à charge
d'accord c'est un investi les donc ça
pour l'état malien bayou le texte
reviendra avant l'été au sénat au sénat
où vous avez où il ya un groupe
écologiste
quelle sera votre stratégie sera une
stratégie constructive à son moi avec ce
groupe mais nous les écologistes on est
toujours constructif dès que ça avance
on est là pour soutenir simplement à ce
stade
vu l'urgence climat vu l'urgence sociale
les petits pas d'aujourd'hui sont des
reculs s'ils voulaient ce projet de loi
aussi peu que ces chats constructif si
vous dites que ce que propose le projet
de loi ne sont des recrues lenglen où ce
sur quoi on se fonde c'est la science
aujourd'hui la science elle dit voilà le
trajectoire pour atteindre moins 40% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
il est moins 55% même si on s'en réfère
aux nouveaux enjeux objectifs adoptés
par l'union européenne qu'est-ce-qui
constructif regarder la réalité telle
qu'elle est ou se contenter des
demi-mesures de ce gouvernement vous
entendent être les garants des
propositions de la convention climat par
exemple dans les propositions énoncées
ce matin par par le groupe écologiste du
sénat il y avait l'interdiction de la
publicité pour les produits les plus
polluants dont les voitures et là pour
le coup revient vraiment aux
propositions du président amant je le
redis les 150 citoyens qui n'étais pas
écologiste début on produit un travail
formidable que nos élus mettent déjà en
oeuvre par exemple à grenoble avec eric
piolle il ya déjà la réduction drastique
de la cid de la publicité et notamment
ses écrans numériques qui salait à votre
attention comme ça une consommation
équivalente
celle d'un ménage pour des produits
parfois extrêmement polluant évidemment
qu'on peut pas être en cohérence
dirigeant fait des efforts et continuer
à 16 gaspillage d'énergie pas possible
consumériste et bien sûr ce soit en
finir avec la publicité en particulier
des écrans numériques est ce que vous
serez le 28 mars dans la rue pour cette
manifestation à laquelle appellent
certains membres de la convention climat
et certaines organisations pour demander
plus d'ambition au texte nous nous y
serons évidemment les écologistes et
nombreux et nombreuses
et moi je me réjouis que l'écologie
comme cela puisse être porté par cette
génération en partie un newsflow klein
etc c'est une mobilisation c'est la
jeunesse qui s'engage dans la rue dans
les urnes demain qui en fait devra
affronter les conséquences de l'inaction
vous serez dans la ruhr 28 mars avec les
conventions mais ça veut dire vraiment
que cette jeunesse est ce on l'a dit
dépolitiser etc
non c'est pas vrai par contre elle
mesure que l'inaction de nos dirigeants
nous mène dans le mur et la met dans le
mur et donc elle elle se saisit elle
serait avait appris la politique et moi
il lance du projet de loi il ya aussi la
généralisation des menus végétariens à
la cantine a lyon on l'a vu il ya les
menus sans viande pas tout à fait pareil
qui font polémique
est ce que vous vous soutenez cette
mesure du maire de lyon grégory de c'est
évidemment évidemment alors d'abord la
mesure où ils résident ou c'était une
mesure temporaire
donc on tout le monde lui est tombé
dessus je pense que j'ai pas compris
pourquoi le ministère manin n'avait rien
de mieux à faire que de s'occuper des
antilles cette mesure alors déjà sur
l'aspect temporaire sur des aspects très
logistique vous avez une 29 mille
enfants à nourrir chaque jour et c'est
plus loin de faire de la viande que de
faire du poisson oui tout à fait tome 2
parce que souvent ces pré cuits et c'est
déjà chaud vous savez on passe et puis
on vous sert mais je vais déjà ses
listes à la france que vous répondrez
vous avez une spéciale c'est le fait de
faire un plat unique qui permettait de
réduire et de faciliter la logistique
avec les nouveaux protocoles sanitaires
plus exigeants vous avez des maires qui
ont laissé tomber à qui on dit c'est
trop compliqué en fait plus mais les
écologistes ont choisi de maintenir la
cantine scolaire aussi pour des
questions et pas aider je suis sûr vous
de faire un menu sans viande halal
garantir aux enfants qui de faire un
menu sans viande en ont par contre si
maintenant alors là c'était vraiment
purement temporaires et je voudrais
pas que grégory douce et soit accusé
d'avoir lui il a il a voulu maintenir la
restauration scolaire maintenant annonce
sur le débat oui nous voulons réduire
l'alimentation carnée et oui c'est
massivement soutenus par la population
là où nous sommes en pré duel supprimés
nous voulons aller sur l'alternative
végétarienne quotidienne et moi demain
si je suis élu ou quand je serai élu
président de la région écologiste dans
les lycées d'île en île de france mais
vous avez comparé la france entière et
j'en profite
c'est une mesure que nous portons
honnart ses dirigeants n'ont rien à
fiche à l'alternative végétarienne
quotidienne via permettre le choix tam
enfin les sarries d'une question coville
et après c'est fini
et oui on va parler du coc évident le
gouvernement qui est le sur le pied de
guerre ce week-end pour montrer qu'il
met le paquet sur la vaccination
plus d'un demi million de vaccins
réalisé en trois jours c'est une
c'était un sujet de réjouissance pour
vous moi je me réjouis quand la
vaccination progresse
évidemment est ce que il ya une partie
du personnel soignant qui est réticent à
se faire vacciner
est ce que ça vous choque c c'est le
fait qu'ils veulent pas se faire
vacciner
écouter vraiment on doit tellement aux
soignants au soignante que je voudrais
pas alimenter de nouvelles polémiques je
ne comprends pas qu'on puisse leur en
vouloir de quoi que ce soit c'est un
choix je pense que rendre la vaccination
obligatoire créerait plus de problèmes
que ça n'en résoudrait et en particulier
s'agissant des soignants et des
soignants enfin julien on leur doit tout
et donc si on devait parler aujourd'hui
des soignants et des soignantes parlant
de leurs conditions de travail
d'ailleurs souvent des soignantes en
cette journée du 8 mars
souvent mal payés mal considérés conte
du mal à se loger près de leur lieu de
travail
le ségur de la santé autre manière de
gagner du temps n'a pas remis la moyenne
des salaires au niveau 2 de l'union
européenne non vraiment ce gouvernement
continue de supprimer des lits je pense
au regroupement de différents hôpitaux
dans le nord de l'essonne par exemple
même si
ça n'arrive pas en france jusqu'à nancy
et nantes vous avez raison on a
également des pertes de l'ipar
secrétaire national santé par centaines
et donc c'est assez malvenu la part de
ce gouvernement de s'en prendre aux
soignants soignante alors qu'il continue
de supprimer des lits voilà nous voulons
soutenir l'hôpital public et ça commence
par ces pas d'obligation de vaccination
pour les soignants je pense que ce
serait contre-productif écologie les
verts vous soutenez la vaccination et
pourtant c'est dans vos rangs qu'on
trouve le plus d'anti anti vaccin anti
vraiment pas bon on se souvient quand
même de la compagnie son d'âge qui sont
sortis sur l'adhésion vaccinale nos
sympathisants sont parmi les plus au
temps avec ceux de la république qui a
pas de réticence
vous vous ferez vacciner quand ce sera
votre tour oui qu'on puisse se retrouver
un semblant de d'activité normal il ya
un enjeu sur la vaccination aujourd'hui
vous voyez ces deux on est sûr ils ne
sont pas des pas des pénuries enfin il y
en a pas pour tout le monde
malheureusement il ya un enjeu de
l'accès à la vaccination pour les pays
les moins développés parce que là
évidemment on est très concentrés sur la
france sur l'europe sur nous et c'est
compréhensible
voilà mais il ya un an je sais que sur
lesquels attirent oxfam attire
l'attention c'est la mise à disposition
de vaccins pour les pays les moins très
important faut faire tomber les brevets
et oui bien sûr bien sûr il faut pouvoir
rémunérer les labos d'une manière ou
d'une autre évidemment mais dès qu'on
peut on penser peut pas on ne peut pas
voyez enfin la vie et la santé ne
peuvent pas être une marchandise comme
les autres
merci brigitte et merci à mme diallo on
va parler d'enseignement supérieur et
frédéric vidal qui a demandé une enquête
après que deux enseignants de l'institut
d'études politiques de grenoble sciences
po comme on dit ont vu leurs noms
affichés parce que suspecté
d'islamophobie
l'union syndicale affiliée à l'unef a
dit regretter ce qu'il s'est passé et
cette affaire relance le débat sur l'
influence de l'islamo gauchisme à
l'université
d'abord est-ce qu'une enquête est
nécessaire pour le moins oui alors déjà
j'aimerais dire que dans ce contexte
actuellement quelques mois seulement
après l'ignoble
attentat qui avait visé qui a coûté la
vie de samuel pâti cette affaire de
remettre des noms d'enseignants comme ça
de jeter en pâture aulas ne fait que
mettre de l'huile sur le feu et
évidemment ces screens on doit pouvoir
assurer la protection des enseignants et
des enseignantes ça c'est absolument
évident et pour vous est-ce que l'islamo
gauchisme est une réalité menace ou pas
essam au gauchisme je crois que c'est le
le nouveau judéo bolchevisme
ça veut absolument rien dire donnez moi
une définition on pourra en discuter en
attendant je crois que c'est si vous
voulez ce qui s'est passé à grenoble
c'est pas forcément ça c'est qu'il ya
des personnes qui ont pu peut-être des
professeurs ce qui mériterait une
enquête c'est que s'est il passé on
n'est pas sûr l'islamo gauchisme
seulement on est sur des professeurs qui
ont pu y avoir des critiques à l'égard
de l'islam ce qui est parfaitement
normal on a droit de critiquer les
religions évidemment ou qui ont pu avoir
des propos provocants ou autre à l'égard
des élèves et qui ont pu sentir
discriminés là dessus vous voulez une
idée là dessus je pense que la
hiérarchie peut-être a tardé à répondre
et c'est là dessus que vous les unes
auxquelles on est un peu comme dont il a
tu voulais une enquête oui voilà c'est
là dessus je pense qu'il faut une
réflexion parce que si en sport c'est un
autre oui ces abus sexuels les nôtres
réalisation patients cerne les sciences
po qui a trait donc aux violences
sexistes et sexuelles dans les yeux et
dans les instituts d'études politiques
finalement n'a encore on a une explosion
dans les réseaux sociaux parce que la
hiérarchie n'a pas condamné parce que
vous avez pu avoir des professeurs qui
avaient des comportements absolument
scandaleux et compris est répréhensible
pénalement et il n'y a pas eu de réponse
voyez ne veut pas de vagues ou ainsi de
suite et ben alors c'est là dessus que
moi j'aimerais que frédéric vidal
s'engage sur quelles réponses à apporter
aux élèves qui dénonce des comportements
des enseignants qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être
qu'ils soient des comportements liés au
comportement violent aux abus sexuels ou
éventuellement au contenu leur
enseignement et à l'islam est d'accord
une protection des enseignants qui
souvent réclament des moyens ou une
écoute qu'ils n'ont pas de leur
hiérarchie et malheureusement la presse
la ministre vidal est absente sur ce
sujet tout le temps alors vous savez
quoi
on va parler des élections régionales en
ile-de-france notamment parce que chaque
chose en son temps
en particulier mais pas qu'eux avec yves
thréard du figaro qui est avec tout bon
soir yves bonsoir francis bonsoir julien
bayou alors avant de parler des
régionales avait parlé un peu à part et
d'autre de politique est plus générale
notamment sur le plan national il ya des
élections présidentielle une élection
présidentielle dans quelques mois et on
sait que chez les écologistes europe
ecologie les verts il ya une candidate
déclarée à me sandrine rousseau et 2 des
classes de candidats possibles
monsieur yannick jadot et monsieur et
monsieur et violent qu'ait le maire de
grenoble vers lequel de ces trois noms
vous vous porteriez vous avec moi je
suis un organisateur de la désignation
et est donc je suis évidemment
impartiale moi je suis garant du votre
avis et d'ailleurs je précise en les
candidatures n'ouvriront qu'en juillet
parce que nous considérons que la
priorité ce sont les élections
régionales
bien sûr c'est pas pour éviter vos
questions 1 mais qu'est ce qui les
différencie ces trois mares fait en
personnalité nous sommes un parti
politique très homogène très cohérent
c'est à dire que je peux pas vous dire
qui a de l'avant sous qui est mieux
placé
ça ce sont les sur le fond les
électrices et les électeurs qui sont qui
vont le départager en revanche on a une
vraie cohérence d'ensemble
les écologistes et donc
on adoptera un socle programmatique en
juillet sera évidemment centré sur une
ambition pro européenne critique du
fonctionnement actuel mais qui veut
travailler avec nos voisins européens
une refonte de la fiscalité pour le
rendre plus juste une transition
écologique et tous les emplois les deux
millions d'emplois qu'on peut aller
chercher des emplois non délocalisables
conduit sens l'égalité femmes-hommes
l'art parlementarisation nettoyer tout
ça constitue un socle et ni et eric
piolle ni yannick jadot ni sandrine
rousseau ne s'en écarte euros ou alors
ils seront obligés d'adhérer à cette
charge non mélicie adhèrent déjà accès
un choc le comporte ensemble depuis des
décennies alors nos curiosités justement
dans votre mouvement c'est que on a
compris que ailleurs au parti socialiste
chez les républicains les primaires
c'était une chose un peu dépassée qui
leur avait fait du mal par le passé mais
vous chaque élection présidentielle vous
organiser une primaire
oui c'est un vote c'est un vote parce
que l'alternative c'est un choix avis
auquel seront pourront se mobiliser
uniquement les adhérents à jour de
cotisation non pourra voter donc les
adhérents et adhérentes évidemment et
puis les sympathisants et sympathisantes
les personnes qui signent une charte
pour une re et accorde écologistes et
qui s'inscriront un peu en amont en
avant deux en avant du vote
d'accord mais oui parce que
l'alternative c'est que je décide avec
quelques autres membres du bureau
exécutif qui est la mieux placée
eh bien nous nous considérons que c'est
une affaire collective la délibération
et de vote sauf qu'à chaque fois que
vous avez pris quelqu'un qui a fait un
très bon score à l'élection
présidentielle non je pense que l'on
peut pas comparer ce qui s'est passé
avant 2019
une vraie lame de fond écologistes aux
élections européennes
qui c'est qui c'est réaffirmant insurgés
les pacages et aux élections municipales
oui je pense fondamentalement d'accord
alors pour finir avec la présidentielle
tout le monde parle beaucoup de
du deuxième tour avant même le premier
tour est exactement est d'ailleurs la
plupart des français ne veulent pas d'un
match retour le pen de macron néanmoins
c'est celui qui risque si on en croit
les sondages d'aujourd'hui qui ne sont
pas prédictifs qui risque de se produire
et il ya une question beaucoup
d'électeurs de gauche déçus par macron
ne souhaite pas faire barrage en cas de
cette finale et ne nierai pas voté pour
emmanuel macron pour faire barrage à
marine le pen
c'est votre cas non nous on est un parti
profondément républicain donc on se pose
à l'extrême droite qui est une menace
pour notre société pour notre république
et donc on choisira toujours le candidat
républicain
simplement je suis pas sûr que le fait
de le dire mobilise les foules puisque
je les dis je le répète
emmanuel macron se présenter comme le
rempart et arrêtent aujourd'hui je crois
qu'il est un carburant du populisme
jeunes et les personnes qui ont voté
pour les questions de fraternité et
d'accueil des réfugiés mesure à quel
point ça sa politique est violente et
brutale
au point qu on la sert détente et qu on
les attaque à la pelleteuse à calais les
personnes qui ont voté pour les
questions d'égalité
il avait un discours sur les personnes
assignées à résidence ont vu très
rapidement qu'en fait ils baissaient des
impôts pour les plus riches mais que
pour toutes les personnes qui n'avaient
pas le sou baisser les aides
personnalisées au logement et sur les
libertés
cette personne qui s'était présentée
confond une révolution démocratique
finalement un parlement aux ordres pour
vous un homme de droit laisse marcher là
la justice fin laisse la droite marché
sur la justice alors que la justice est
passée sur la justice pas il est pour le
coup vous pouvez pas lui reprocher
aujourd'hui on vient à l'imiter
les libertés publiques y compris le
droit de la presse dessus des
manifestations donc je pense que
vraiment sa politique est un carburant
du chaos c'est un régime autoritaire
je pense que cette affaire de jupiter sa
vision de mépris les corps
intermédiaires et de la concertation
avec les élus locaux y pose en tout cas
les bases
d'une dérive autoritaire clairement une
dérive autoritaire chez emmanuel macron
non ça pose les bases si vous venez d'un
scénario à la hongroise ainsi d'
aventure un gouvernement d'extrême
droite
prenez le pouvoir on sait que la vème
république offre énormément de pouvoir
aux calendes la république est lui
plutôt que de tempérer avec des
contre-pouvoirs et et déséquilibre en
joue à plein et je pense que ce n'est
pas bon pour le pays alors vous êtes
candidat à l'élection régionale puisque
c'est dans l'île de france c'est de
saison à l'île de france ça a lieu la
deuxième quinzaine du mois de juin on a
vu que dans les hauts de france on n'est
pas loin d'un accord entre europe
ecologie les verts est là la france un
soubise ski d'agresser et le parti
sécessionniste
c'est l'union de la gauche dont tout le
monde parle et que peu faisait est ce
que vous pourriez gagner cette région
écoutez ça ça dépend des électrices et
des électeurs nous notre enjeu derrière
karima delli
c'est de porter un projet écologiste et
le propose un rassemblement sur la base
d'un projet écologiste et moi je me
réjouis que en particulier dans cette
région où il ya un risque que le
rassemblement national puisse l'emporter
je me réjouis que karima delli et les
autres forces de gauche puissent
discuter et peut-être aboutir en a copié
accord est alors en ile-de-france est ce
que cet accord j'ai entendu dire que
vous pourriez vous vous entendre par
exemple avec clémentine autain qui est
la représentante de la france a soumises
à cette élection régionale
il n'y a pas de nous l'enjeu je vous
fais la même réponse c'est de porter un
projet écologiste est donc en ile de
france où il n'y a pas ce risque
des victoires du rassemblement national
eh bien nous portons un projet
écologiste la france insoumise va
proposer j'imagine un projet inspiré des
thèses insoumise audrey pulvar la
candidate socialiste proposera un projet
socialiste
je la laisserai le développer il y dix
ans que la locomotive d'un rassemblement
au second tour ça peut-être l'écologie
sauf que au premier tour si l'aventuré
vous vous étiez ensemble avec madame
cottin selon les sondages où seriez
entre 20 et 25%
là j'ai pas loin devant les socialistes
et pas loin de madame pécresse
j'ai pas vu ce type de configuration
nous l'enjeu c'est de porter un projet
écologiste la région aujourd'hui il ya
plus de la moitié des personnes qui
voudraient la quitter jusqu'à elle est
trop chère trop pollué trop stressante
et parce que valérie pécresse n'a rien
fait pour améliorer cette situation
nous disons c'est l'écologie qui peut
apporter bien vivre intérieur très
limitées dans les transports et le
développement économique qui va avec la
toile à cette dernière question de lui
l'enjeu c'est de battre adam demain
battre si l'enjeu c'est de constituer
l'ossature d'une alternative à cette
droite qui as et clientéliste et qui ne
fait rien pour la région merci francis
vous était resté là parce que ça m'a
fait penser à d'autres petites choses
que j'avais dit jean luc mélenchon lui
il a dit hier sur france 3 que il ne
donnerait pas de consigne de vote au
second tour en cas de face-à-face macron
le pen vous vous donneriez des gels dit
j'y viendrai ce que vous donnerez une
consigne de vote
je les dis nous ne sommes pas outillés
républicain d'accord mais je viens de
nos riches consignes de va toujours à
battre l'extranet de dollars voté pour
le candidat république ce serait une
consigne claire oui d'accord d'accord
dont psa est ok pour le front
républicain pour le faux réplique et une
deuxième petite chose est simplement
simplement ce président ben oui
aujourd'hui on a 40 52 toujours dans ces
sondages
nous nous employons à construire
l'alternative aujourd'hui on a 48 52
avec une marge d'erreur de trois points
donc on est on est sur la ligne d'
alerte ce président de la république est
celui par qui le chaos peut arriver
notamment s'il s'acharne avec cette
mesure de l'injuste sur la réforme de la
sionge merci de ne pas lutter contre les
inégalités inégalités merci merci
francis merci j avais aussi beaucoup on
est dix ans après l'explosion de la
centrale nucléaire de fukushima au japon
à la suite d'un tsunami on se souvient
de ces images
et de cette catastrophe dix ans après en
france en alsace la centrale de
fessenheim a fermé c'était une
revendication des écologistes est ce que
ça vous le mettez au crédit de ce
quinquennat
oui oui évidemment enfin c'était une
proposition et un engagement du candidat
hollande et qu'il n'avait pas tenus et
puis emmanuel macron l'a fait il était
temps il faut dire que c'était la
doyenne de nos centrales nucléaires vous
mettez au crédit des sur une zone
sismique et sur une zone inondable et
donc évidemment voilà l'enjeu l'enjeu
c'est de pouvoir
et ça pour le coup malheureusement ça
n'avance pas dans le même temps que nous
engagions la sortie progressive du
nucléaire
personne ne dit qu'il faut faire mais
nucléaire tout de suite nous disons
fermant les centrales au fur et à mesure
de leur obsolescence et engageant la
montée en puissance des énergies
renouvelables parce qu'ils ont joué
jusqu'à 50 ans malheureusement c'est pas
ce que fait le goodwill par contre
fessenheim c'est à mettre au crédit du
quinquennat oui d'accord on va cueillir
maintenant deux parlementaires qui vont
débattre avec vous
les deux les deux parlementaires sont
nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau martha
de sidrac et sandra martin bonsoir à
toutes les deux vous allez pouvoir
débattre tout à l'heure martin décidera
que vous êtes sénatrice les républicains
des yvelines alors on va parler un peu
guides de france n'est pas que et sandra
botha vous êtes député la république en
marche de l'isère et donc vous êtes avec
nous sur ce plateau ce soir pour
débattre avec julien bayou on va
commencer par fab éthiques
martin décidera que vous allez nous
parler de la loi climat sur laquelle
vous avez rebondir aussi sandra bottin
je pense que ça va être un débat
intéressant parce que vous vous demandez
quel va être le comportement des
écologistes voilà dans ce débat oui en
fait vous avez déjà dit beaucoup de
choses monsieur bayou sur la loi climat
et notamment toutes les critiques en
fait que vous avez partagé tout à
l'heure moi je voudrais revenir en
réalité sur un petit peu votre position
aujourd'hui puisque et puis aussi ce que
vous pensez du parlement tant que tel
parce que parfois je suis un tout petit
peu étonné de certaines de vos
interviews et de certaines prises de
paroles très critiques sur la forme très
critique sur le fond même si je peux
partager un certain nombre de critiques
sur la forme sur le fond vous savez bien
ça a commencé d'ailleurs à l'assemblée
nationale le débat est en cours il va
arriver également au sénat et vous dites
il eût fallu en réalité que le texte ne
soit absolument pas modifié par rapport
aux propositions qui ont été faites par
les conventionnels et le du travail qui
a été fait à la convention citoyenne
sans commande la question maintenant
c'est le président qui l'avait promis
oui mais aujourd'hui
pardon pardon aujourd'hui ce texte de la
de loi on voit bien 69 articles 5 mille
amendements sauf erreur de ma part
ça prouve bien que le travail
parlementaire et bien enclenché qu'il va
y avoir un enrichissement en tant que
rapporteur de la loi geiq je peux en
dire quelque chose très articles au
départ la loi geiq 130
au final donc on voit bien que le
travail parlementaire enrichi tout texte
de loi quels qu'ils soient sont pour
autant être offensant sur un travail
quel qu'il eut été et donc moi ma
question je la recommence je la répète
aujourd'hui quel est votre avis du
parlement et du travail du parlement
tout simplement vous êtes dedans
fonctions politiques importantes je
pense que vous avez du respect pour le
parlement mais ça ne se voit pas
beaucoup dans vos propos alors c'est
jésus est très mal m'exprimer moi j'ai
le plus profond respect pour la fonction
et législatives nous souhaitons
d'ailleurs lui redonner du pouvoir avec
une révision constitutionnelle qui a été
maintes fois promise de re
parlementarisation de notre régime
la proportionnelle mais pas uniquement
un premier ministre qui a beaucoup plus
de pouvoirs un parlement qui est maître
de son agenda ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui et j'ai insisté seulement
sur un point important c'est que à
l'issue de la convention avant la
convention citoyenne pour le climat le
président avait dit je les reprendrai
son filtre donc si vous voulez c'est au
président que vous devez faire ce grief
de marché sur le parlement moi je trouve
qu'il ya beaucoup d'hypocrisie
parce que il a une majorité très
confortable à l'assemblée et donc s'ils
avaient voulu faire passer n'importe
quel projet de loi vous et moi savons
qu'ils auraient pu le faire et il l'a
fait il a pris prétexte que il y avait
des débats dans la société pharmec et
sion ok je viens si ça ne répond pas la
question c'est est une question c'est
est-ce que les députés les députés les
sénateurs ont changé il a priori en état
de s'exprimer il a dit je reprendrai
sans filtre et moi je trouve que quand
un président la république et au
gouvernement sans filtre il a fait je
trouve que quand un président s'engage
sa parole elle doit être honorée et que
sinon ils abîment la parole pour les
question n'est pas sur ce que pensent ou
pas le président ma question porte sur
ce que vous vieillissez et souffrez que
je pourrais m'en excuse confiance vous
accordez à la représentation nationale
député sénateur fleurs la loi pour faire
la loi geoffrey est ce que c'est de ça
dont on parle c'est vrai que je vous
réponde quand même le président
aujourd'hui à complètement dénaturé le
haut conseil pour le climat le le dit
les grandes associations le disent les
conventionnels le disent a complètement
dénaturé ce projet qui est très très en
deçà des ambitions affichées donc sur
cet aspect il ya eu mensonge sur la
question du parlement je moi je regrette
que le parlement n'ait pas assez de
pouvoir dans notre démocratie et
notamment que les parlementaires en
particulier ceux de la majorité de l
harlem soit sous la coupe du
gouvernement est que quand ils ont
malheur de se poser au gouvernement on
les refasse voter je trouve que ça
témoigne
plutôt d'un mépris à l'égard de
l'institution législative et c'est pour
ça que je le redis nous écologistes
android dans une république où le
parlement est beaucoup plus de pouvoir
calculer bravo ça je vous rassure et le
parlement à tous ses pouvoirs
et quand on revote c'est simplement de
la procédure législative ça c'est tout
continuera ce maire ne pouvez pas vous
assure monsieur my hand dans les yeux
que c'est vrai c'est tout à fait vrai et
tout ça n'est vraiment qu'une question
procédure pour le coup moi je souhaitais
vous interroger sur un autre aspect de
cette fois climat qui m'a bien que vous
avez tmg dans tous les sens pas voulu
choisir bien sûr mais si vous savez je
suis au coeur de cette machine depuis
quatre ans je vois bien comment elle
fonctionne et je vous assure
en tant que majorité en tant que député
de la majorité que j'ai toujours voté
avec mon plein au libre arbitre fois par
exemple n'importe quoi par exemple si on
parle de l'importance du travail
législatif le droit d'amendement qui est
garanti dans la constitution pourquoi
est il bafoué aujourd'hui quand des
parlementaires comme matthieu orphelin
et delphine batho tous les deux députés
proposent des amendements et qu'ils sont
jugés irrecevables par le président de
l'aim bien sans doute monsieur b you
parce qu'il ya un texte monsieur bayou
qui est supérieure à tous les autres
ça s'appelle jeanne constitution article
45 exactement mais aussi de 45 articles
40 d'ailleurs je tiens aux deux parce
qu'en tant que les milliards aux
finances habituellement je tiens aux
deux et donc il est prêt il me protège à
la fois le texte que nous votons l'objet
de nos discussions et il nous évite de
parler de la pluie et du beau temps
quand on est censé parler de choses
importantes comme la question que je
voudrais voudrais vous adresser par
exemple sur ce texte donc que vous
décriez autant et qui pourtant va
obliger toutes les métropoles de plus de
cent cinquante mille habitants d'ici à
2024 à faire ce qu'on appelle des zones
à faibles émissions pour les mobilités
donc à cette date les voitures qui ont
une vignette critères trois quatre ou
cinq ne pourront plus rentrer dans ces
zones
pas plus pour aller travailler pour
aller au musée pour le cinéma ou même
pour aller dans les commerces de
proximité dans la métropole lyonnaise
vos amis messieurs douce et et bernard
envisage même de d'exclure les voitures
critères deux perles ne permettant plus
quasiment à personne de rentrer dans la
ville de lyon ce que je déplore
particulièrement mais donc quand on veut
faire ça ce qu'il faut c'est proposer
des solutions gens notamment des
transports en commun
alors du coup je voudrais savoir quelle
est un peu votre stratégie sur ses
transports en commun quand aujourd'hui
vous vous opposez dans le val d'oise à
la création d'une gare à gonesse qui
contrairement à ce que vous pensez enfin
semblé penser n'est pas juste un endroit
où les gens passent c'est aussi un
endroit où 26 mille habitants vivent
rien dedans connaissent pas les
alentours
et donc ma question est la suivante
c'est quelle est votre stratégie
réellement en matière de transport pour
les habitants des banlieues pour ne pas
les assigne à résidence et ne pas leur
mettre un gilet jaune sur le dos si vous
refusez de mailler le territoire avec de
nouvelles gares alors nous l'enjeu pour
la région ile de france mais c'est
valable dans beaucoup d'autres régions
c'est de pouvoir développer une offre un
plan de transports à 15 minutes de chez
vous qui n'est plus de déplacements sans
solution alternative à la voiture donc
évident quand on interdit d des
transports polluants comme la voiture et
autres il faut pouvoir permettre aux
ménages les plus défavorisés de s'en
passer
soit en changeant de voitures soit en
ayant une offre de transport
alternatives et donc d ailleurs ce que
cet égard c'est d'ailleurs ce que va
faire bruno bernard et grégory douce est
ce qu'ils vont faire a pas chez moi je
vous assure c'est un peu ce qui manque
pour en avoir discuté il ya 48 heures
avec lui je peux vous dire qu'ils vont
justement médecins en oeuvre ou sinon
exempter les gens de cette obligation
sur la gare de gonesse vous dites 26
mille habitants à gonesse pour robin
c'est pourquoi on fait pas la gare à
gonesse parce que vous oubliez de dire
qu'elle est à 2 km 1 km 7 précisément
avec zéro habitants 1 km 7 à la ronde
nous nous disons au milieu de nulle part
un sur 27 s'est pas au milieu de nulle
part et je pense qu'en vélo vaut 15
minutes vous les avez non et pour vous
faites pas à gonesse mais nous disons ce
sont 300 hectares de terres agricoles
que nous voulons protéger cette gare au
départ elle était prévue pour accueillir
le grand centre commercial europa city
qui a été abandonnée forte heureusement
parce qu'ils étaient pas d'acteur pour
les ter avis à vous pouvez aussi nous en
rendre et prédateurs pour le petit
commerce
pas de pas de grand centre commercial
pas de gare ou alors appât médias là à
gonesse pourquoi pas de garde contre il
va y avoir un dirigeant g
réalisation plutôt qu'à un autre en fait
en quoi les 1 km 7 vous pose un souci
parce que vous êtes en plein champs et
nous disons qu'il faut protéger ces
terres agricoles que l'organisation
mondiale de la santé l'onu toutes les
organisations nous exhorte à adopter le
zéro artificielle ils sont honnêtes à
protéger ces espaces agricoles et de
biodiversité à mettre en oeuvre des
stratégies de circuits courts pour notre
alimentation à soutenir la gros hic à
agro écologie et les emplois qui vont
dans le texte de la loi climat si je
vous suis bien puisqu'il y aura la
guerre à la baisse de 50% de
l'artificialisation des noms votre bilan
bien jaune commercial depuis votre
l'évidence et d'avoir réintroduit des
néonicotinoïdes pour l'instant les
pesticides tueurs d'abeilles c'est ça le
bilan de la majorité dans la violence et
d'avoir sauvé la filière sur la bière en
france
effectivement les gens suivront bien oui
bravo bien sûr bravo vendre on est on
est sur le même niveau de débat que on a
pu entendre sur l'amiante ou le
chlordécone avec des gens qui disait ok
c'est nocif pour la santé
mais tant pis on continue pour les
connais même avec l'amiante à l'époque
on pouvait la manger et cessa de
reprendre ce titre coeur simplement nous
nous disons des nervis entérite qui
était de 119 il ya la santé doit
prévaloir et donc oui il ya des dizaines
de milliers de morts de la pollution
chaque année et donc c'est une changes
continue m let's dance pour une gare
alors même que le projet europa city et
a certes été abandonné mais qu'un autre
projet va être proposée justement par
les élus de ce territoire et qui ne sera
pas aussi important que le rck à city
mais y aura bien un projet il y aura
bien un développement ça donne envie
d'en changer d'enseigné km 7 c'est de le
faire à gonesse vous dites un kilomètre
7 b pourquoi vous imposez 20 minutes de
de transport de vélos autres en vélo
c'est terrible pour la sentent alors que
la guerre pourrait être à gonesse
mais il par ailleurs au passage on se
saoule à ses 300 hectares qui serait
irrémédiablement perdu leur père y aura
un autre projet du lion aujourd'hui nous
dire qu'on peut comme ça massacrées 300
hectares de terre agricole val d'oise y
savent à quoi s'en tenir avec moi en
tout cas
parce que nos priorités c'est la
rénovation du rer b et d et si on parle
du val d'oise désolé de rentrer un peu
lent mais c'est sa centaine de milles à
la prolongation de ce tram à sarcelles
ou la mise en place d'une interconnexion
sur la ligne e h à saint denis s'est pas
c'est pas dans le val d'oise mais ça
permet aux habitants du val d'oise
d'être honnêtes personnes par jour un
jour quand même portail décidera que
vous vous êtes rapporteur au sénat sur
le climat et sénatrices et républicains
des yvelines donc c'est dans la région
parisienne justement la plus grosse
région de france quand vous entendez
julien bayou dire il va falloir
équilibrer entre tous les modes de
transport express que vous êtes
convaincu vaut par sa évidemment qu'il
faut équilibre on peut pas ne pas être
d'accord avec ce que dit julien bayou là
la question que l'on doit se poser c'est
quel est le projet que je lis un bayou
porte pour la région ile de france
donc voilà je crois que sur si on juge
les gens sur les paroles on sera très
rapidement peut-être d'accord les uns
les autres mais c'est pas ça le sujet et
moi je vais prendre un exemple très
simple monsieur bailly aujourd'hui vous
souhaité briguer la région ile de france
aujourd'hui
cette région est présidée par valérie
pécresse et vous n'arrêtez pas d'être
particulièrement critique vis-à-vis en
fait de sa gestion des lycées et moi je
voudrais quand même rappeler avant
d'aller un tout petit peu plus loin vous
même vous avez été membre de l'ancienne
majorité à l'île de france
on sait en 2015 dans quel état nos
lycées se trouvait à ce moment là à tel
point qu'il a fallu débloquer un grand
menton 6 milliards quand même d'euros
pour pouvoir mettre ne serait-ce que un
petit peu d'argent et un petit peu
d'investissements dans nos lycées qui
aujourd'hui sont dans une situation
calamiteuse vous le dites vous même mais
à qui la faute à qui la faute à qui la
faute monsieur ben alors moi je vais
vous dire je veux dire pascal et et moi
je suis dans une région
dans une ville où nous avons une
concentration lycéenne comme nulle part
ailleurs saint germain en laye que
peut-être vous connaissez à
saint-germain-en-laye je peux vous dire
que par le passé on n'a jamais vu un
conseiller régional venir entendre ce
que les élus du terrain demandez à la
région depuis qu'il y à valérie pécresse
on sent très clairement qu' il y à une
amélioration je prends pour exemple les
40 millions investis dans les toilettes
je prends pour exemple les
investissements qui sont faits dans un
certain nombre de nos lycées or vous
êtes très critique
moi j'aimerais comprendre je vous dis
cette espèce d'incohérence entre des
décisions à l'époque et des décisions
que vous ne souhaitez pas voter pour des
lycées qui sont fondamentaux aujourd'hui
le court je veux dire l'enjeu c'est
qu'il ya un retard incroyable qui a été
pris
quand valérie pécresse arrive à la tête
de la région el dia un tiers des lycées
qui sont venus mais qu'est ce qu'elle
fait elle fait rien depuis les amplis
l'élan depuis 2000 15 depuis 2005 47
l'opération jamais 47 opérations
disons les chiffres et 20 cette année il
ya 500 lycées vous êtes un chrtr
monsieur là oui excusez moi donc vous
avez eu la chance d'avoir un lycée sur
votre territoire karité et rénové c'est
pas le cas de coulommiers par exemple il
a fallu une mobilisation sans précédent
des lycéens des parents d'élèves pour
obtenir que les médias s'intéressent à
la situation des pétitions et autres et
qu est-ce qu elle est venue sur pascal
avenue endroit l'état de nos embauches
réalisées à qui attend des doigts
répondez-moi juste à cette question elle
est sympa mais je vous rencontre doit-on
l'état des lycées hérité en 2015 et vous
savez quelle majorité
vous savez répond développe justement
intéressant ça mais moi ça m'intéresse
que c'est de l'argent mais maintenant je
me dis on est obligé d'être aujourd'hui
dans nos lycées pour pouvoir pallier à
tout fonctionne pas a été fait mais vous
le faites ça le problème c'est que moi
je voterai dès demain s'il y avait un
vrai plan d'urgence
je lui même avec lui loin le fassiez
avant 2040
cette base 47 opérations en 50 et le
fassiez avant de mon adresse à deux là
peut-être que vous avez néantiser en
prenaient même insisté sur un point
parce que aujourd'hui quand il ya des
opérations elles sont rares je vous dis
47 s'est pas beaucoup ces bruits du vent
si lafarge qui en bénéficient nous nous
voulons mettre en place un small
business act et le fait que cet argent
bénéficie finalement aux très petites et
moyennes entreprises de la rénovation
des bureaux d'études de l'artisanat la
maintenance alou tire les marchés
publics pour que ce ne soit pas que les
grands qui en bénéficient mais que
l'airé les entreprises de nos
territoires puissent aussi participé de
l'effort est évidemment à voir le carnet
de commandes et les emplois qui vont
avec
voilà de la vision si vous en voulez la
transition ou la transition écologique
et pourvoyeuse d'emplois privés le
mieux-être pour notre région mais vous
décrivez en réalité une situation à
laquelle vous n'avez absolument pas vous
n'avez rien fait quand il fallait le
faire et aujourd'hui vos critiques et
des investissements qui se font dans les
lycées justement pour permettre
d'améliorer le coût de cette opération
j'ai amélioré le quotidien de nos
lycéens d'améliorer le quotidien de
leurs enseignants d'améliorer l'ensemble
du quotidien des personnels de ces
lycées je me réjouis que saint germain
en laye et puis bénéficié du soutien de
la présidente parce qu'elle est issue
des yvelines moi je souhaite que la
région elles soient pas centré sur les
yvelines ou centré sur paris mais
qu'elles puissent bénéficier de la
condamnation et les sons et les ces
petites et moyennes aux lycéens
et ça je pense que ç'a failli dans le
précédent mandat
je le regrette profondément temps qui a
le francilien devra se décentrer pour se
concentrer sur autre chose avec sandra
botha pour parler de deux justices tda
réforme de la justice
tout à fait le garde des sceaux dupont
enfin mettre fin à monsieur dupont
moretti éric dupond bray voilà je suis
le prénom tête donc a commencé à
dévoiler sa réforme une réforme de la
justice qui va être qui a vocation fait
à renouer fille de la confiance entre
les français et la justice vient qui
s'est distendu au fil des ans et des
critiques virulentes de certains à son
égard je souhaiterais à ce sujet vous
entendre sur deux mesures phares de ce
texte la première c'est celle qui rend
en fait le pouvoir des citoyens dans les
procès d'assises pour une part eu la
voie là puisque donc on va augmenter le
nombre des jurés citoyens qui seront
amenés à juger des hommes et des femmes
qui ont commis des crimes des meurtres
des vols des viols en permettant aussi
de mieux organiser ses procès où se
relaient en fait experts et témoins sans
qu'on en trouve toujours le ni la raison
ni l'intérêt donc voilà sur ce sur ce
premier point de la justice des assises
donc et une meilleure représentation des
citoyens j'aurais souhaité vous entendre
pour savoir ce que vous en pensez
il ya des sujets intéressants je me le
dire comme je vous dis quand ça va dans
le bon sens je le dis il ya des sujets
intéressants dans ce projet loin en
particulier les la création de droits
sociaux pour les détenus ou cela la
france est régulièrement épinglée pour
l'état de ses prisons
malheureusement ça ça ne change pas et
pour les conditions inhumaines qui a pu
être réservé aux détenus on a des record
de surpopulation la réponse c'est
souvent en construire plus de prisons au
lieu de s'intéresser sur sortir du tout
carcéral
mais évidemment donner des droits aux
détenus me semble une une avancée utile
donc ça c'est par exemple un point que
je retiendrai de ce projet de loi je
dois apporter un tout petit codicille un
désole c'est que fin août nous avions eu
l'honneur de recevoir dupond moretti à
nos journées d'été où nous avait annoncé
en grande pompe la création de l'éco
sida qui est une norme indications de
longue date des écologistes quand un
dommage irréversible et causés à
l'environnement
il n'en est rien finalement on est à
peine un délit que vous ne pouvez pas
activé il est fait pour que ça ne marche
pas ça on en discutera après si vous
voulez mais en gros aujourd'hui dans ce
cas là la rédaction du délit aussi est
fait pour que ça ne puisse pas être
active
il a bien sûr que si et le deuxième
point qui nous des provisions la
généralisation des bracelets pour
écarter les maris violents
ou les les conjoints violents conjoint
violent les prédateurs en matière de
violences sexistes et sexuelles
je cite c'était pour les semaines qui
venait et malheureusement nous attendons
toujours
et donc il ya un décalage est là encore
entre les discours et les le deuxième
point vous vouliez vous que le deuxième
point sur cette rive
vous en avez un peu parlé c'est
justement qui touche en fait à l'open
c'est la refonte globale du mécanisme
des peines pour qu'elle ne soit plus
automatique parce que les peines enfin
les réductions de peines automatiques ça
choque non seulement les victimes mais
ça décourage aussi les policiers et les
gendarmes qui est qui travaillent dur
pour trouver qui sont les coupables sept
cette réforme c'est très font en fait de
ce système de remises de peine il va
reposer sur la réelle volonté de
réinsertion des détenus leur
comportement pendant lors de leur
détention
parce que soyons bien clair ce ne sont
pas les hommes et les que l'on juge ce
sont leurs actes
donc j'aurais souhaité savoir là aussi
ce que vous pensez de cette là encore ça
peut aller dans le bon sens pensée
soumis à l'autorité du juge
d'application des peines
le terme automatique était un peu
surfait parce que deux fêtes en cas de
mauvais comportements évidemment ça
saute et plus fins d'abord quand je
rentrais dans l'oeuf le mans series avec
quand même déjà prendre le matelot
prendre de manière différente et tu peut
s'entendre tout à fait encore une fois
ça dépend de l'autorité du juge mais
j'insiste la france à une surpopulation
carcérale construire des prisons n'est
pas la solution
c'est souvent même l'école du crime et
donc le jeune maurice je voulais pas
quand on dit les gens vont passer plus
de temps en prison
c'est vrai qu'on réfléchit à d'autres
d'autres manières de prévenir et
sanctionner mais tant que c'est sous
l'autorité d'un juge d'application des
peines évidemment tout va bien moi je
veux être clair les gens ne passeront
pas plus de temps en prison parce qu'on
va arrêter
l'automaticité de ses réductions de
peine puisque en réalité ils pourront
avoir plus de réductions pennetier se
comporte bien et surtout on aura cette
libération sous contrainte qui deviendra
un droit également pour ceux qui ont des
peines de moins de deux ans et pour
finir leur pelle chez eux plutôt que
dans une prison pour favoriser la
réinsertion changement d'équilibré mais
vous dire que sur les deux points là il
ya des liens matière à discuter oui tout
à fait
après le gouvernement ne fait pas que de
mauvaises choses et je suis très
heureuse de pouvoir mais je pense qu'il
ya matière à discuter en effet donc
c'est quelque chose sur lequel nous les
parlementaires au sénat nous allons
également évidemment nous exprimer c'est
évident mais par exemple notamment sur
les peines qui ne sont pas réduites
automatiquement ça pour les républicains
ça vous voir pourquoi pas oui il faut
tout à fait donc il ya des choses qui
sont positives et d'autres sur
lesquelles nous sommes nous nous portons
un regard un peu plus critique c'est
c'est eh on va rejoindre maintenant
filière volaille vincent roux qui nous
attend bonfort vincent et vous avez une
vie vincent comme tous les lundis à
cette heure-là ce que les internautes ou
les lecteurs ou l'été les lecteurs du
figaro ceux qui vous suivent sur figaro
live et téléspectateurs ont retenu
d'actualité à ce qui a beaucoup marqué
les internautes du figaro dernièrement
c'est une déclaration qui a été faite
d'ailleurs sur le figaro au grand jury
rtl lci le figaro
hier par elisabeth moreno qui s'est dit
favorable à titre personnel à la gpa
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
traduire je traduis gestation pour
autrui alors la gestation pour autrui
il faudrait expliquer ce que sais je
c'est finalement le fait dès lors
comment dire louez le ventre d'une femme
un peu compliqué de l'autre précise
présenté comme ça je vais vous aider je
voulais c'est au bled pour permettre à
quelqu'un d'avoir des enfants
moi aujourd'hui je ne sais pas le faire
sans que ça dégénère sur les trafics
on nage et peu d'exemples de personnes
où ça peut s'organiser de manière
bénévole sans qu'il y ait de risque que
ça dégénère sur des trafics et de la
traite d'êtres humains et en particulier
à nouveau et toujours les femmes et donc
moins à ce stade je n'ai pas de solution
pour une gpa éthiques
si vous voulez tout vous êtes contre la
gemmi oppose eh bien oui je me pose
passant sur le plan de ce que vous
appelez la gpa éthique c'est à dire une
gpa où il n'y a pas de trafic
est-ce que les changes dans tout ça est
ce que vous trouvez ça pardonnez moi de
vous poser la question comme ça mais
très écologique c'est une bonne question
c'est à dire en quoi c'est une bonne
question josé bové par exemple était
contre la pma parce qu'il estimait que
ces trafics et la neige alors vraiment
par l'anpans pour le coup mais je vous
dis clairement parce que c'est ça qu'il
veut dire 20 mai pma et gpa
si ce n'est la ressemblance des cibles
n'ont absolument rien à voir non je ne
sais pas ça la question oui mais la
question est ce que vous y voyez de
manipulation des réactions pensons aux
on en attend 10 kg hab an sont les
enfants qui sont nés sous pma ou qu'ils
ont dans leur classe des enfants qui
sont nés sous pma et si on commence à
raconter que sais je sais pas quoi
manipulation et c'est enfin les mots
sont blessants nous la procréation
médicalement assistée qui est utilisé de
manière commune par nombre de couples
hétéros et j'espère désormais bientôt
par des couples lesbiens ou des femmes
seules et bien c'est une bonne chose oui
c'est un les surveiller et volleye je
reviens là dessus mais vraiment 10
secondes
est-ce que la gpa pour vous ce serait
synonyme de manipulation de l'humain
j'ai moi je mets ça que vous demandez
s'ils sont vraiment gêné sur les pma et
gpa non non on parle que de gpa
l'amérindien donc moi je vous ai dit mon
en jeu ma question c'est la question de
comment éviter si on allait sur cette
voie moi je le souhaite pas comment
éviter la traite des humains bien
merci va sûrement des femmes pas de
manipulation de l'humain danser dans ces
actions là c'est pour ça que moi je vous
réponds sur la question là c'est pour ça
que moi je vous réponds sur la traite
des humains
merci vincent merci vincent voulait
absolument pas inquiété
non non je croyais je croyais en tout
cas merci martin
[Musique]